listen one one resolution he didn't say
that we were all hoping for maybe was
that we would secure our border right
didn't we kind of expect him maybe to
say that was going to be his resolution
maybe not well in either case whether
it's his resolution or not the truth is
this month December of this year more
than 300,000 migrants have crossed our
border that that is a record and a
threshold we've never touched before
that puts us at
785,000 more than our fiscal year today
so that's back just back to October 1 so
that's just over the last 3 months so
that's where we are with our open border
that those in the White House would have
you believe is somehow secure well I
don't think it was going to be his New
Year's resolution because this is
entirely intentional this is as planned
the only problem is he doesn't want us
to see those numbers and draw attention
to it frankly if you're not watching Fox
News you're not likely to see those
numbers um they just don't they just
don't talk about it on the other network
and that's such an important point butd
for the gr reporting for Bill Mion I
spent a lot of time in eag pass and
others and our drone team Fox's drone
flight team that were there lonely when
even there was a report of there showing
the numbers coming across so much so
that CNN MSNBC Now cover this this
headline and just in the last hour and a
half I got a call from my CBP Source it
puts these numbers out that there are
now more than 302,000 migrant encounters
a number never thought imaginable in our
border just in 2021 of December it was
74,000 now it's over
300,000 and and I got to tell you in all
honesty when I heard a little before
Christmas December 21st Karin jeanpierre
stand at the White House Podium and say
this my jaw dropped
watch and what we're seeing here at the
border the migration flow uh increased
migration flow certainly uh it you know
it es and flows and we're at a time of
the year where we're seeing more
at the border and it's not unusual Not
Unusual she is at best oblivious to what
is happening which is the worst
humanitarian crisis in the National
Security crisis or she is lying and not
just lying intentionally lying to paint
a narrative that is anything but the
truth when you have the humanitarian and
national security threat risk happening
every single day at that border I think
it's interesting you brought up the
drones because if you recall I maybe a
lot of our viewers can remember back um
when I first realized that fox was using
drones to you know see what was going on
was over the uh the bridge where all the
Haitians had had gathered and Pete
Buddha judge who we're going to talk
about a little bit later in the show
with Congressman um van Orton bu Buddha
judge tried to stop the fox Jones
correct yeah they did they they did they
he did not want you to see that and now
even still to this day we don't have
unfettered access to the Border but but
but for the Drone we're able to show you
and and what you're looking at is look
at that is is more than 150 countries
from Eagle Pass Texas all the way out
west to lukeville Arizona a thousand
miles separate these two areas both
areas where the border patrol agents
here in Eagle Pass they average 3,000 a
day now they have no more than 20 no
more than 40 20 to 40 agents on shift
it's 100 to1 200 to1 outnumbered and yet
you're hearing Congress is about to come
back they're fighting over funding we've
got to have funding for Ukraine and
funding for the Border but what I'm
watching and this is the last point I'll
make but I'm watching very closely is
what they'll do will they change policy
in their border reform or will they just
allocate more money which is going to
add 10 20 more agents per sector to do
more transporting and processing because
when you occupy all of the agents time
transporting and processing it leaves
hundreds of miles of wide open border
for the cartels to exploit and that's
the problem is there's two terms here we
kind of conflate that are two different
things there's border crossers and
Border jumpers now border jumping is
basically entering illegal and not being
inter interdicted in any way you jump
the Border you get here no you never are
are in any kind of entanglement with law
enforcement in any way you make your way
into the country we want to call those
known guideways I hate that term because
at best known guideways simply describes
the amount of people we saw a camera or
felt on a sensor it doesn't describe the
amount of people that were never
detected so what are the unknown
guideways how many people get through
the border and what are they doing you
know even if it's less people are those
the ones that are bringing drugs and
terrorists across the border we don't
know because we don't have an
opportunity to know because we don't
have the resources to know you know what
might have helped it would would have
been I don't know maybe a sturdy wall
that we literally pay to sit in a scrap
peep right now you no that you're
absolutely right that would have been a
lot more affordable we're spending more
just in this city alone to take care of
illegal immigrants than the cost of the
wall uh I think what we don't talk
enough about because we look at these
images and and we see these numbers that
come from Griff and others um to our
Network and it's just so mind-boggling I
don't think we spend enough time talking
about Brian bber talked about the taxes
but what are the other consequences on
the American people how does this
directly affect your life life into the
future and I believe that this Invasion
and there's no way you can call
something that you're seeing right there
anything other than inv an invasion what
are the long-term consequences on your
taxes on on the American budget but more
importantly even just on the culture
because none of these people are going
to be assimilated in a way that we're
familiar with I can say that as a the
daughter of a legal immigrant so how
does that impact our country as a whole
we have not even begun to imp unpack
that I'm Steve duy I'm Brian kilme and
I'm Angley Airhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling
analysis